voters arrived early to cast their
ballots
technical and logistical problems were
reported at some polling stations voters
will come out well
as expected and everyone will vote in
peace
but overall
voting went smoothly
members of the maasai community wore
their traditional clothing as they
waited patiently in line i'm expecting
that
there is going to be peace the people of
kenya are going to elect leaders of
their choice the leaders that they know
they are going to even change the
economy of this country
deputy president william ruto voted in
his home county in the rift valley he's
one of the front runners for the
presidency i feel very good
that after so many months of campaigning
and speaking to the people of kenya
and selling our agenda
and our manifesto
and having
discussions across the country
this morning
it's d-day
his rival opposition leader rylo dinger
voted at a polling station in nairobi
accompanied by scores of supporters
outgoing president uhuru kenyatta voted
in central kenya after falling out with
his deputy kenyatta has backed odinga to
succeed him do you believe this election
will be free and fair it is every every
kenyans hope that that is the way it
shall be do you hope so absolutely
some analysts say kenyans want
politicians to focus on issues like the
economy most of the people we have
spoken to share the same concerns the
cost of living is very high people have
no jobs they're worried about corruption
they hope
their new leadership will make things
better kenya has a history of election
violence this year voters say they hope
the outcome of the polls reflects the
true will of the people catherine soy
al-jazeera nairobi